foreign
comes from Katie in Oregon Katie writes
about seven years ago my parents had
asked me to get a home together with him
at the time we were in an apartment with
a baby and our home buying option was
taking longer as my husband is
self-employed I said no many times but
after being asked over and over again my
husband and I agreed here I am seven
years later and miserable yes my parents
put the house in their name with only me
on the mortgage I'm not even on the deed
Oh Katie they tell me that I can't be on
the deed due to the fact that they are
over 65 and will say on taxes that's
insane my husband completely renovated
the home spending many thousands of
dollars as the house was falling apart
when we purchased it we pay 80 of the
house bills and whenever something
happens we fix it ourselves and put a
ton of money into it
at this point my parents know I'm
unhappy but they have informed me that
if we decide to sell the house they will
be keeping most of the profit because
they are retired and will need it
whereas we are still young and working
we have no money saved up because it has
been all spent in this home which has
led to some debt as well I feel like
we've been fixing a home that we simply
rent my parents have complete control
legally and financially I feel so
helpless lost and have and taken
advantage of
that's it wow
well okay let's forget all the other
stuff let me just I'll just say this
Katie you have been taking advantage of
and you knew this was gonna happen you
knew it that's why you fought it for so
long because this kind of this kind of
these two your parents they didn't just
suddenly turn into this they've been
like this your whole life and you knew
this was a bad idea and you kept going
back because you had this imaginary
fantasy that one day we're all gonna be
one big happy family and they kept
saying well if we're gonna be a happy
family then you have to give us this
house and your parents hear me have
stolen from you
if they have used you taken from you and
stolen from you if I'm you I forget the
parents part now let's put the parent
part aside there's two adults who are
stealing from you robbing melting your
marriage and taking all of your money
for you and your small family I would
figure out whatever way I can get out of
this thing as quickly as possible if I
have to sue them possibly consider that
because they are stealing from you and
if not if you don't want to sue them
then you walk away with the loss you
walk away and learn your lesson and you
and your husband lick your wounds and
y'all go on the next I mean it's just
grosses me out I know at the beginning I
was trying to go back and reread did is
she living in the house with them yeah
yeah so they're all living in house yeah
so Katie I'd move out and I would be
done with it
um I would ask them yeah to get your
name off the mortgage if you need if
they need to refinance whatever they
have to do get your name I would I would
break this deal and if they won't pick
your name off the mortgage then you you
list the house for sale yeah because
you're I mean yeah I yeah that's the
number one thing and again I know
there's a lot of loss here from the
financial standpoint because you guys
have spent all of your savings all of
your debt and also though Katie like you
you and your husband have to take a look
in the mirror and be like wow we chose
this like we're adults we chose this for
seven years and we and we made this
decision so it it's a it's a complete
change not just from a financial living
perspective Katie but this is how you're
gonna basically View and what you're
communicating to your parents which is
the first time you've ever done it as
and you're an adult you're an adult and
this is what needs to happen because
John's right they've taken complete
Advantage you guys okay so John from
like a psychological standpoint when
parents do this maybe I'm very naive
but there's like that innate sense that
majority of and I know there's like
really toxic abusive situations right in
the world but parents like this Katie's
situation do they think that they're do
they know what they're doing or in their
minds this is the right thing like you
know what I mean like is it malicious
for parents like this in this type of
relationship like do they know what
they're doing or in their like Backwards
Minds no no we're helping them but no
they're not I mean when they say like if
you sell we're taking on it all and like
they know it's theirs right
um no I I think what happens there there
becomes an a you owe me
like like I and I've heard this I bought
you groceries I made sure you always had
clothes and I did I you see me get irate
I don't ever get mad you know that
I get like that makes you they're your
kid of course like that wasn't an
investment that you were owed this back
later with interest right right I give
you a house for 18 years
yes
you made them into the world that's
right it is on you right right right so
there is a well I did this and so like
we just don't have anything because yeah
like you you gotta take care of your
parents and so it's I I don't want to go
down the diagnostic route
um but it's just a gross situation
because
whether you're six or whether you're 26
whether you're 46.
nobody wants to think my parents are are
preying on me right are using me right
and so you spend seven years 30 years
trying to fix that relationship because
somehow you think you're doing something
wrong because they would never do that
because they're your mom they're your
dad and it's a scary moment when
somebody like me tells you you have to
walk away because they're they're going
to kill you yeah right they're robbing
you blind yeah absolutely it's hard to
like oh my gosh just shake that reality
because Rachel no matter what happens in
your life whatever hell you go through
whatever terrible decisions you make
yeah there should always be two people
that you know the doors open if you if
you need somewhere to go and Katie has
learned the hard way that door's closed
she cannot go to them because they'll
steal from her and that's a that's a
soul-shaking bone rattling realization
for for folks yeah it's hard and then it
takes a situation like a messy house
situation
financially to wake up to that emotional
sense of oh my gosh this is the reality
my reality is my parents steal for me
yeah and they're stealing from their
grandkid yeah my parents will steal from
their grandchild for their own
entitlement sake what do you say to
people because I've heard you mentioned
it earlier I kind of go back to it
um because I've heard a lot on this show
and even talking to people this sense of
it is my it's my responsibility it is my
duty to take care of my parents and if
they're 70 years old with no retirement
uh you know or whatever the situation is
and we have money like it is out I need
to take care of them because of you know
what they did and they're you know
they're not asking or maybe they are
asking
for a for an adult child
and their parent relationship what does
that look like when the parents is the
one that needs help and the child child
maybe can provide but doesn't you don't
need to feel obligated in that like
what's that boundary yeah I I probably
have a little bit different take on it I
and I
can get all philosophical about it I
just know that if my mom was she's in
her 70s if my dad passed away and she's
like I have nothing
I would have a sense of obligation I
gotta figure out someone help her yes
um the two big things are number one me
and my household me and my wife me and
my kids we're whole we're good and so I
we put our oxygen mask on first we're no
good helping somebody else to your and
you die in the process doesn't help
anybody right so if you financially
can't if you are underwater and you
can't you don't have any money to give
and we've been on the show you and I
have been taking calls where someone's
like I need you to open up some credit
cards because I have to pay groceries
well she's 66 and doesn't want to I
don't care what she wants to She's Gotta
Eat that means she's gotta go work right
so number one you have to be whole and
number two you have to draw some
boundaries and that is not whatever they
want
they want us to take over the mortgage
because they want to keep living in this
house
no they can move in the apartment down
the street from you where you live if
that's what y'all can afford with the
rent that's right right but they're
grown-ups and they can opt out of the
help I'm able and willing to provide but
it's going to come with some boundaries
so the first one is you got to be whole
and your marriage has to be good you all
have to be okay financially and two you
all have to sit down and say Here's what
we're willing to do or not do um it's
that that old honor your father and
mother doesn't mean do whatever they say
for as long as they say even when it's
abusive or even when it's theft right
right or even when it's gonna crush your
own children that's not honoring your
household right yeah yeah um but it also
means sorry old man you shouldn't no I'm
gonna help and take care of my parents
if I've got the means and ability I'm
gonna reach out yep because I think
that's what's so hard about situations
like this and Katie's like I know is a
little different but but it is that idea
of like oh my gosh like they are my
parents but when the roles reverse and
you're in a better place financially
than your parents or even emotional
you're in a healthier place and you're
probably like it's weird when that
transition happens but it happens for a
lot of people and those of you listening
maybe on the track of like becoming debt
free and having savings all of it so you
may find yourself in that position of
I'm so much better off than my parents
are what is my obligation what does that
role look like so that's so helpful John
thanks so much